Hazel Brugger der Comedy-Star mit dem
Pokerface eine Meisterin des finsteren Humors.
Ihre Geschichten spannen sich
von der Geburt bis zum Tod.
Wenn man es runterbricht sind Geburt und Tod das Einzige, was absolut relevant ist für jeden.
Weil das das Einzige ist, was jeder macht.
Sie selbst kommt 1993 in den USA zur
Welt,
wächst im Zürcher Unterland auf.
Meine Damen und Herren, ja, wir fangen gleich an.
Kaum angefangen geht's steil und schnell
aufwärts
Als 19-jähriger wird Brugger Schweizermeisterin im Poetry Slam
bald folgt ihr erstes abendfüllendes
Bühnenprogramm.
Stellen sie sich mal ein Schweizer
Diktator vor, also wie soll denn das aussehen?
Wer soll denn das machen?
DJ Bobo oder Roger Federer
mehr haben wir einfach  nicht!
Ihr Studium bricht sie
vorerst ab.
Lieber plant Brugger Auftritte auf Papier,
schreibt unter anderem für das Magazin
Kolumnen,
die schließlich in einem Buch erscheinen.
Seit ihren Auftritten bei der
satirischen "heute show "
avanciert Brugger
im deutschsprachigen Raum zur Berühmtheit
"Sie wirken extrem gut gelaunt, trotz dieses desaströsen Jahres für die CDU,
ist das Optimismus oder Naivität?"
Als Reporterin mischt
sie sich unter Politiker.
Ich bin jetzt keine Frau - Also sie sagen sie sind jetzt keine Frau,  sie waren auch nie eine und sie werden nie eine sein, oder ist das offen?
Nein. Ich war keine, bin keine und werde wahrscheinlich nie eine sein.
Brugger räumt ab was es in ihrer Branche
zu gewinnen gibt,
darunter auch den renommierten "Salzburger Stier".
Ein beliebter Gast in TV-Satire Formaten.
Hazel, was möchtest du trinken?
Ich nehme ein Wasser gerne.
Wasser? Du trinkst keinen Alkohol?
Nicht mit so vielen alten Männern gleichzeitig!
So jung, so erfolgreich.
Brugger hat gut lachen.
Trotz Poker Face.
Hallo! - Hallo!
Hazel - Nina - machen wir Du! Gerne!
Lass uns reingehen.
Dann kannst du gleich die Bühne anschauen.
Du hast mal gesagt:
Niemand der normal ist hat Humor.
Humor setze ein ewiges Gefühl
von Unausgeglichenheit voraus.
Was ist denn das für eine Art von Humor?
Was heisst Humor für in dem Falle?
Ich glaube Humor dann der Versuch mit dem umzugehen, das einem sich nicht gut fühlen lässt.
Ich bin jemand der sich nicht wohl fühlt
in zu grossen Gruppen
Also wenn mehr als 10 Leute an einer Party sind, dann fühle ich mich eigentlich gar nicht wohl.
Ich habe gerne maximal 5 Leute,
dann kann man noch ein ernstes Gespräch führen.
Sonst fange ich einfach an ausschliesslich humoristische Beiträge einzustreuen.
Damit ich meinen Beitrag zu dem Gespräch geleistet habe. Ohne etwas von mir preiszugeben.
Was musst du denn auf der Bühne von dir persönlich preisgeben, damit es klappt?
Ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig wenn man die Leute längerfristig zum Lachen bringen will,
mit den Mitteln die ich habe
also mit meiner Stimme und meinem Körper
dass man sich einigermassen verletzlich macht,
also dass man zeigt:
"Hey,  mir wichtig dass ihr lacht,
wenn ihr das nicht macht,
dann nehme ich das persönlich."
Und dann tut das mir auch weh,
aber dann werde ich das aushalten können.
"Eine Person die geklatscht hat,
also falls das noch einmal passieren sollte heute Abend
wenn jemand alleine anfängt zu klatschen -
Bitte klatschen sie einfach mit!
Mir bricht jedes mal das Herz
so ein bisschen
wenn jemand in einem ausverkauften Haus alleine anfängt zu klatschen.
Offensichtlich ist diese Person ja total sozial inkompatibel also - *Lachen & Applaus*
Hast du dir die Technik so selber
erarbeitet,
oder gibt es das Leute,
die du in Anspruch nimmst  als Coach
Also einen direkten Coach habe ich nicht,
ich glaube das gibt es in der Schweiz auch nicht wirklich.
Aber ich schaue halt viel Comedy und trete sehr oft auf,
dann merkt man auch, was gut funktioniert
und was einem liegt,
Und dann habe ich schon auch 4 -5 Freunde,
die mir sagen:
"Hey mach das mal anders, oder das
ist schon recht gut so",
und dann ist es auch wichtig dass man offen bleibt
für Veränderungen und Vorschläge.
"Ich bin eigentlich eine wahnsinnig
nette Person
gefangen im Körper von Jemandem
der überhaupt nicht nett ist
der medizinische Fachausdruck dafür ist Transsympathisch."
Zu dem "offen bleiben" gehört auch
das Improvisieren ad hoc,
wie wichtig ist dir das mittlerweile?
Sehr wichtig.
Also merke ich dass das etwas ist was ich mir nie komplett verbauen will.
Ich möchte nie in etwas gefangen sein, in dem ich mich kein bisschen mehr frei bewegen kann.
Auch wenn es nur 2 Minuten sind von 90, ich möchte einfach die Möglichkeit haben zu improvisieren -
so wie du jetzt auch, oder?
- Voll, ich gebe mir total Mühe!
"Hier ist so ein Notizbuch.
Das sieht für das ungeübte Auge jetzt natürlich aus als würde ich Notizen lesen.
Das stimmt natürlich nicht, ich bin Profi.
Hier sind einfach Bilder drin
die mich so bisschen beruhigen.
Ich bin sonst so eine
überdrehte Personen
und brauche da ab und zu mal
eine optische Stütze die mich relaxt.
Das sind jetzt heute Abend hier
rasierte Tiere beim Sport. "
Du bist einerseits in der Schweiz
unterwegs und dann zum Beispiel in Deutschland,
und ich das Gefühl das ist schon
ein ziemlicher Gap teilweise,
was die Leute wie verstehen
- empfindest du das auch so?
Nein, das empfinde ich nicht so extrem ...
- Die lachen einfach alle?  - Nein!
Ich glaube die, die mich lustig finden,
die finden mich auf beide Sprachen lustig.
Denn wir sind ja schon beide sehr ähnlich sozialisiert.
"Es tut mir leid wenn sie jetzt gehört haben dass ich aus der Schweiz komme
und enttäuscht sind "Warum redet sie nicht noch behinderter?"
Ich habe mir das ab trainiert.
Ich habe es mir mühselig ab trainiert,
aber ich weiss natürlich es gibt diesen Fetisch.
Ich will den auch bedienen,
und deswegen begrüsse ich sie ganz kurz
auf Schweizerdeutsch,
damit wir das abgehakt haben:
Gchrrrg.
So. Das war das.
Für mich geht in dieser Sendung noch
ein lange gehegter Traum in Erfüllung.
Den hast du dir letztes Jahr erfüllen können: Ich treffe Helge Schneider.
Wie war es?
Super!
Er ist ein super Typ.
Mega lustiger Mensch,
natürlich irgendwie unendlich Gaga auf eine Art.
Aber natürlich auf die beste Art die man sich
wünschen kann.
Ist er für dich denn auch ein berufliches Vorbild?
Helge Schneider ist auf jeden Fall ein berufliches Vorbild für mich,
aber nicht in dem Sinne, dass ich beruflich das machen will, was er macht
weil er ist in erster Linie einfach ein verdammt guter Musiker.
und das bin ich nicht.
Was ich halt sehr schön finde bei Helge Schneider ist,
dass er eine neue Messlatte im deutschsprachigen Raum gelegt hat
für das, was Humor darf und nicht muss.
Und dass sich Humor - seit es Helge Schneider gibt - weniger legitimieren muss.
Helge ist so gut und so lustig dass man gar nicht fragt:
"Was ist denn ihre Nachricht an die Welt, wenn sie über das Katzenklo singen?"
Niemand würde das fragen.
In den 60er Jahren war Joggen auch etwas Neues
da fragte man: "Wo rennst du denn hin?"
Und dann sagte man: "Ich renne einfach!" "Was du rennst einfach? Das ist ja voll gestört."
Und mittlerweile rennen die Leute einfach.
Ich habe heute im Zug vier Senioren gefragt: "Kennen sie Hazel Brugger?" - Stille.
"Kennen sie Helge Schneider?" - "Nein."
Ich glaube nicht, dass es Leute gibt die mich kennen, und Helge Schneider nicht.
Das wäre als ob man Afri Cola kennt, aber noch nie von Coca Cola gehört hat.
Helge ist schon "the original".